queen elizabeth ii is speaking out
following meghan markle and
prince harry's explosive interview with
oprah winfrey there's a conversation
with you with harry about
how dark your baby is going to be
potentially and what that would mean or
look like
and you're not going to tell me who had
the conversation
i think that would be very damaging to
them on tuesday buckingham palace
released a statement on behalf of her
majesty the queen
nearly two days after megan and harry
addressed
everything from feeling trapped to
personal struggles with mental health
and allegations of racism within the
institution
you certainly must have had some
conversations with harry about it and
have your own suspicions
as to why they didn't want to make
archie a prince
what are what are those thoughts
why do you think that is do you think
it's because of his race
the statement explains that the family
is saddened to learn how
challenging the last few years have been
for megan and harry
adding that the issues raised
particularly that of race are concerning
the talk of the palace is that they are
absolutely horrified
by what has been said they feel that
harry has literally thrown
the family under a bus but while some
recollections may vary
they are taken very seriously and will
be addressed by the family privately
harry megan and archie will always be
much-loved family members
during the interview megan claimed there
were concerns and conversations about
how dark their son archie's skin might
be when he was born
in those months when i was pregnant all
around this same time
so we have in tandem the conversation of
he won't be
given security he's not going to be
given a title
and also concerns and conversations
about how dark his skin might be when
he's born
harry later confirmed to oprah that a
conversation about archie's skin color
did take place
but he wasn't comfortable sharing more
details
that conversation i'm never going to
share
but at the time at the time it was
awkward i was a bit shocked
um can you can you tell us what the
question was no
i'm not comfortable sharing that on
monday during a chat with cbs this
morning
oprah revealed that harry had told her
that those remarks were not made by his
grandmother the queen
or his grandfather prince philip the
problem with all of this speculation and
names being banded around is that it
does cause
it does cause a huge amount of damage
and suggestions that it might be
the prince of wales and that that is why
he and harry have fallen out and harry
has said he feels let down by his father
are very damaging
to the prince of wales's reputation and
you know ditto prince william et spoke
with royal expert katie nicholl on
tuesday
and she opened up about how the palace
was responding to the backlash
while they were braced for for something
explosive they totally underestimated
just how far harry and megan would go
they took everyone by surprise
katie told et that the royal family was
taking the couple's allegations
seriously and that they would have no
choice but to respond
there is clearly a lot of pressure on
the royal family to break their silence
the age-old mantra which has kept the
queen in good stead all of these years
has been
never complain never explained but i
think such is the severity
of these allegations um the
reverberations of which are being felt
not just here in britain and across the
pond in the states but around the world
are so serious that there really is a
lot of pressure
for a statement to be released from
buckingham palace with some sort of an
explanation
[Music]